-The president went on Fox News
and lied to millions of people
about the coronavirus outbreak
as his administration bungles
its response to the crisis.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I think it's safe to say
at this point
that the president
of the United States
is undermining public health.
And I'm not just saying that
because he looks like
an "Outbreak" monkey
that escaped from a lab.
[ Laughter ]
Trump keeps lying to people
about the potential threat
posed by the spread
of the coronavirus
while the United States
lags behind other countries
in testing, even though
we've had time to learn
from their experiences.
One infectious disease expert
called the lack
of widespread accurate testing
a national scandal.
For example, the CDC website
said today
that 1,500 patients
had been tested just at CDC.
Meanwhile,
"Bloomberg News" reported
that in a short space of time,
South Korea has managed to test
more than 140,000 people,
and they're using an ingenious
new way to do it.
-Outside of China, South Korea
has the most coronavirus cases.
They've come up with
a new innovative way to test
for the virus in the form
of a drive-through.
-I'm going to show you
drive-through coronavirus
testing.
This is a free service
that the city of Goyang
is offering anybody.
Vehicles come through here,
and you get a questionnaire.
You get your hands sanitized,
and then you go through
a number of stations here.
The patients
never get out of the car.
They come in,
they fill out questionnaires,
find out whether or not
they're in a risk category,
and while sitting in their cars,
the nurses will swab their
nostrils and their throats,
take samples,
and then the results
will come in within
two to three days.
This could be a model
for countries like the U.S.
that are just starting to
deal with their first
coronavirus cases.
-Of course, it should be
a model for us.
Look, we might be bad at stuff
like health care, education,
gun control, climate change,
housing, criminal justice,
and gender equality,
but nobody is better than us
at drive-throughs!
I mean, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And nothing, nothing should
appeal to our president more
than treating healthcare
like fast food.
All we have to do is put
"coronavirus testing"
on the menu at every Wendy's,
and he'd go get one himself.
[ As Trump ] Yeah, I'll have
four bacon cheeseburgers,
two Frosties, chicken nuggets,
and a cheek swab. Yeah.
And maybe supersize that swab.
I've got cheeks like a mainsail.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And yet,
we haven't gotten truth,
transparency, or testing
from the president.
And that's because
from the very moment
news of the outbreak
began to spread,
Trump seemed to want
to wish it away
by denying the reality
of the situation
and telling people that one day,
the virus would just
magically disappear.
-You have 15 people,
and the 15 within
a couple of days
is going to be down
to close to zero.
We're going down, not up.
We're going very substantially
down, not up.
I really think, doctor,
you ought to treat this
like you treat the flu, right?
And, you know, it's going
to be -- it's going to be --
Looks like by April, you know,
in theory,
when it gets a little warmer,
it miraculously goes away.
Hope that's true.
It's going to disappear.
One day, it's like a miracle,
it will disappear.
-As a general rule, never trust
someone's medical advice
when they use the word
"miracle."
If you ask someone to look
at a rash, and they say,
"It will go away,"
and you ask how,
and they say, "Like a miracle,"
you need to go buy
some ointment.
Also, I don't trust Donald Trump
on the subject
of medical advice or miracles.
-I have a great relationship
with God.
God is the ultimate.
I mean, God created this.
So, uh, nobody,
no thing, no --
there's nothing like God.
The Bible certainly is one of --
if not --
I mean, it is the book.
-Do you actively go to church?
-Well, I go as much as I can,
always on Christmas,
always on Easter,
and during the Sundays,
I'm a Sunday church person.
-Oh, are you
a Sunday church person?
As opposed to, like, a Tuesday
afternoon church person?
Trump sounds like an atheist cop
going undercover as a priest
to spy on a bunch
of Catholic mobsters.
"So, uh, Father,
what do you think
of our Lord and savior,
Jesus Christ?"
[ As Trump ] Oh, J.C.?
Well, you know,
he's just the ultimate.
And the Bible, of course,
that's just the book, you know?
And I go to church on Sundays.
You guys, too?
Get me out of here!
They're on to me!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Trump's been trying to pretend
the problem doesn't exist
because he knows
he'll get blamed for it.
And he knows that because if
he weren't president right now,
he'd definitely be blaming
whoever was president.
In fact, yesterday, he even lied
and blamed a past president
for the current lack of testing.
-The Obama administration
made a decision on testing
that turned out to be very
detrimental to what we're doing
and we undid that decision
a few days ago
so that the testing
can take place
in a much more accurate
and rapid fashion.
-You can't blame Obama
for something that didn't exist
when he left office.
[ As Trump ] Obama should
have never green-lit "Cats."
I mean, you either go full cats
or full people.
[ Normal voice ] And it won't
surprise you to learn
that this lie
was immediately debunked.
Even the White House
couldn't explain it.
CNN reported that a source close
to the coronavirus task force
said it's not clear where Trump
got his information.
I have an idea
where he got it --
the same place he gets
all his ideas.
I won't say where it is, but I
just hope he washed his hands.
Trump knows this whole thing
could be a challenge for him
politically and for the economy,
which is all that matters
to him.
In fact, MSNBC reported
that during Trump's trip
to India last month,
he was paying close attention
to TV news reports,
not about the virus,
but about the stock market.
-Our reporting indicates
that while he was in India
he was watching the stock market
reaction very closely.
He was very nervous and upset
to see what was happening
with the stock market.
He seemed to be more aware
of what was happening
with the stock market than
what was actually happening
with developments
with the virus.
-Of course,
because the stock market
is the only thing Trump
cares about.
If you told Trump
that spreading the coronavirus
would actually help
the stock market,
he'd be doing press conferences
giving people the opposite
advice of doctors.
[ As Trump ] Remember
not to block your sneezes,
lick stuff in public,
and just touch your face
as much as possible.
Just really get your fingers
in there, knead it like dough.
[ Normal voice ]
Trump desperately wants to wish
the situation away to avoid
political accountability.
That's why he decided
to call in
to his favorite propaganda
network, Fox News,
and spread disinformation
about the virus last night.
For example,
the World Health Organization
announced this week that
the official mortality rate
for the coronavirus so far
has been 3.4%
compared to the flu
which is about 0.1%.
Now, with aggressive measures
in testing,
experts say
it's certainly possible
that number will come down.
Instead,
Trump told Fox News host,
Sean Hannity,
in a phone interview
that he straight-up
doesn't believe those numbers.
-We had a report today
that global death rate at 3.4%,
and a report that the Olympics
could be delayed.
Your reaction to that?
-Well, I think the 3.4%
is really a false number.
Now, this is just my hunch.
I think that
that number is very high.
I think the number --
personally, I would say
the number is way under 1%.
-Why are you going
on national television
and contradicting experts
based on a hunch?
First of all, the only hunch
of yours that I trust
is the one in your back after
an hour at one of your rallies.
I mean, look at him.
Normally, you only hide
your face like that
when you're at a restaurant
with your girlfriend
and you see your wife
at the other table.
[ As Trump ] I love you, baby,
and I don't care who knows.
Oh [bleep] Carol!
[ Normal voice ]
So, Trump lied to viewers
about the mortality rate.
Then there's the fact
that employers
and public health experts
are urging anyone
with any symptoms to stay home
and self-quarantine
rather than go to work and
potentially spread the virus.
Just yesterday,
a county in Washington
officially recommended
teleworking,
and both Amazon and Facebook
asked their Seattle employees
to stay home.
But again, Dr. Trump disagreed.
-A lot of people will have this,
and it's very mild.
They'll get better very rapidly.
They don't even see a doctor.
They don't even call a doctor.
You never hear about
those people.
So, if, you know,
we have thousands
or hundreds of thousands of
people that get better just by,
you know, sitting around
and even going to work,
some of them go to work,
but they get better.
-So now he's telling people
it's okay to go to work
if they're sick.
This from a guy who doesn't even
go to work when he's healthy.
[ Laughter ]
So, the president
is spreading misinformation
about a public health crisis
in order to avoid
political consequences.
But at least he knows
the name of the virus, right?
-So, you can't put them down
in the category
of the overall population
in terms of this corona flu.
-Jesus. The corona flu?
Not only is he lying,
he's making up new diseases now.
[ As Trump ] It's called
the "corona swine Ebola flu."
We just came up with it.
It was very exciting.
You can find it on the
drive-through menu at Wendy's.
[ Normal voice ] This is
the kind of public health crisis
that tests the competence
and honesty of our president,
and obviously,
Trump is completely unequipped
on both counts.
We need truth, transparency,
and testing,
and we're not going to get it
from Donald Trump.
Then again, that's...
-Just my hunch.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪